>> Male Presenter: Good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen.
Hopefully everyone on VC can hear us.
Uh, my name is Dontae Rayford, and on behalf
of Authors@Google and the Black Googler Network,
I’m really excited to announce today’s
speaker, Mr. Baratunde Thurston.
Um, Baratunde is described as a politically
active, tech loving comedian.
He currently serves as the Director of Digital
for The Onion, and he’s also the co-founder
of Jack and Jill Politics.
He is a D.C. native, graduated from Harvard
University, and he currently lives in Brooklyn,
New York.
His first book, How to Be Black, which he’s
here to speak to us about today, was published
this month, black history month, February
2012 by Harper Collins.
Without further ado, I’d like to welcome
Mr. Baratunde Thurston.
[Applause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: What’s up everybody?
[Audience murmurs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Happy black history
month.
Give yourselves a round of applause for black
people.
[Applause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: All people, but especially,
especially us.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: It’s, uh, it’s
good to be here at the Googleplex.
I saw some strange, you have like a, sort
of E.T. type pod going on.
There’s like these zipped up tents that
people are workin' in.
And then I met someone, she said she worked
in People Operations.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And I was, are you
experimenting on the human genome?
Like, it’s just a little disconcerting.
Basically, for those of you watching on video,
this may be my last appearance in public.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Tell my family I love
them, very much.
Uh, I wanna talk about, uh, “blackness”,
the book, my life, a little bit of tech stuff
and wrap it all into one.
Why don’t we just get started with this,
uh, first a little bit more background of,
uh, who I am.
I’m a stand-up comic.
I’ve been doing comedy for about ten years.
I started off in Boston and moved to New York
four and a half, five years ago.
I co-founded this blog, Jack and Jill Politics.
It started in the summer of 2006 with Cheryl
Contee.
And it’s a blog about U.S. politics, usually
from a black perspective.
The watermelon is our logo, and that symbolizes
intelligence.
Most smart people love watermelon and that’s
really all that there is to it.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: If you see something
else you should get yourself checked out cause
you have issues.
You know, watermelon is just wonderful.
I hosted a TV show on Discovery Science channel
a few years ago called Popular Science's Future
Of, and it was really cool for me to be able
to do this show.
We traveled around the world looking at questions
about how we might live in ten to twenty years.
The future of sex, future of play, future
of habitat and what I learned most importantly
is that in the future, all black people will
be required to wear wet suites.
So make sure you get yours, uh, because supplies
are running out.
Global warming is coming.
I now, uh, work as Director of Digital for
The Onion, America’s finest news source.
I’ve been there for over four years and
I’ve had a great time.
My chief contribution, however, is to be every
black person in all the images that The Onion
uses in this journalism.
[laughter] In this case, I played Obama’s
hillbilly half cousin, Cooter Obama, and threaten
to derail his campaign.
Obviously, Cooter did not succeed, and others
are still attempting to derail the president.
Um, and I, this is a very important aspect
of my life.
I do a lot of public service work, a lot of
community service and sort of volunteer efforts.
And, the chief thing that I do is I live hate
tweet the Twilight movies.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And so what that means
is, first of all Twilight is a terrible, terrible
thing.
It’s basically like a stalker positioned
as an object of desire to convince young girls
that they want to live this sort of life that’s
very, very destructive to their egos and their
self-esteem.
And it’s horrible for America and the world,
so I tried to do what I can.
So opening weekends I go to the theater, I
sit in the back, and I live tweet the movie
but with hate.
So I call it live hate tweeting.
And it’s amazing.
I’ve convinced several people not to see
it.
It’s been worth that investment of my time.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I kinda feel like that
teacher that wants to reach one student, you
know if you could just change one life.
Uh, so if I could just convince one person
not to spend fifteen dollars on garbage, then
I’ve done my job as a citizen.
So that’s pretty cool.
And then I’ve written this book and that’s
what we’re here to talk mostly about.
Uh, the book is called How to Be Black.
I have a very simple marketing message, if
you don’t buy the book, you’re a racist.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And that’s just true,
it’s not like a thing, it’s not a hook,
it’s not a scam.
And it works, it works.
We actually found out, uh, after the first
week, that we made the New York Times best
seller list.
So guilt works ladies and gentlemen.
[Cheering]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I highly recommend
it.
You guys should try it in your, in your Google
products.
And those of you at home, your products as
well.
So before I keep going forward I want to go
back a little bit and then tell you not just
what I’ve been up to, but where I’ve come
from, and I’ll go back a couple generations.
This is an image of my great grandfather,
Benjamin Lonesome, born in 1870 in Caroline
County, Virginia, born a slave, taught himself
to read, as the family story goes, and moved
to Washington, D.C.
Now some of you are thinking, “Born a slave
after the emancipation proclamation?”
Government doesn’t always work ladies and
gentlemen.
Government doesn’t always work.
Decrees are not always adhered to.
But, he moved to D.C. and he worked for the
city and he lived to be quite old actually,
he had two daughters.
One of whom was Lorraine Martin, who I didn’t
find out until 2005, that she was the first
black employee in the US Supreme Court building.
And we found all these clips in our mom’s
stuff.
Our mom had passed away, so we’re going
through trying to figure out what to keep
and what not to keep.
We’re like, “Hey, we have this great family
history we did not know about.”
Now, our grandmother was a very proud woman.
She’s pretty well educated for the time.
She traveled a lot more than was normal for
black people of the era.
She did not necessarily spend a lot of her
own time, uh, raising her own daughter.
She had this really adorable daughter.
This is my mother, Arnita Thurston.
You can see where my cuteness comes from.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So she sent, our grandmother
sent our mother off to Boarding School at
age 8.
In a little town called Cornwells Heights,
Pennsylvania.
At the time it was a rural farming community,
now it’s a thriving suburb of Philadelphia.
And my mother had some trouble adjusting to
this environment, little black girl away from
her home in the city cast off into an all-black
Catholic boarding school.
Kareem Abdul Jabbar went to this boarding
school.
He was not Kareem Abdul Jabbar at the time
he went there.
I’m not sure they would have admitted him,
uh, if he had been.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: But my mother had some
tough times at this school.
So tough that she wrote letters back to her
mother and I want to share just one of them
that my sister and I found.
This is letter, in the 8-year-old handwriting,
sent from a daughter to her mother, “Dear
Mother, I am having fun but I do not like
it here.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: “I am mad at you.
Please send me some cookies.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Very important.
“And a Sparkle Plenty doll.”
Sparkle Plenty was this character, very, very
popular back in the 40s and 50s.
“Please, uh, they can have dolls here.
Please send it because I do not have anything
to play with.
Yours Truly, Arnita.
So it’s an adorable, sad letter from a daughter
to her mother.
But I want you to focus on the lower left
corner of this letter.
This very neat handwriting, very different
font, uh, different color scheme, says “over.”
When you flip the letter over you see this
note, which says, “If your little girl is
dissatisfied, we’d be glad to have her bed
for children who are anxious to come.”
Signed, “Sister” Which is sort of like
the NSA wiretapping of, I guess, 1948.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: You gotta protect the
nation from little black girls that want dolls
and cookies.
It’s very much a threat to the nation.
So my mother did not stay long at that school.
But she did stay within the confines of what
was expected of a modern Negro woman.
This is her as a teenager wearing a dress
below the knees, carrying a basket, probably
full of happy feelings about America.
I’m sure what was in that basket.
She worked at her high school newspaper, but
before long her social network changed and
she started hanging out with people that looked
like this.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: This is a dude name
El Dorado.
[Laughter]
[Murmurs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Like the car.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And there are many
people in this world who, uh, who think they’re
cool.
Some people watching this right now think
you’re cool and know people who are cool.
You’re not.
You’re friends aren’t.
This dude, El Dorado, is the last cool person
to ever have existed.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Look at the shoes,
look at the phone; look at the typewriter,
the pants, the hair, everything about this
picture is cool.
Cool is now a historic relic thanks to the
high bar El Dorado set.
But my mom didn’t stop there.
She started getting political.
She was joining rallies.
She was out in the streets.
This is African Liberation Day Parade outside
of Malcolm X Park in Washington, D.C., headed
south on 16th street northwest.
And right in the thick of it is my mom.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Cause the revolution
may not be televised but it could be photographed.
You want your hair done up right.
You want the eyes focused on the camera.
[Pause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Now, when I was born,
my mother did not leave these politics behind,
she very much infused them with me.
A lot of kids had little books when they were,
you know, you had cartoons.
You had See Spot Run and stuff like that.
I didn’t have that.
This was my first book, pretty much.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Called This is Apartheid.
>> Baratunde Thurston: I had another book
called Africa is Not a Country, it’s a Continent.
And when you are raised with this, like stark
black and white photos of Apartheid.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: It maybe has a little
effect on you as a young person whose mind
is being molded.
Now, outside of our house is a very different
picture.
This was a constant view from our front window
of Newton Street in the Columbia Heights neighborhood
of Washington, D.C.
Lots of drugs deals and other stuff going
on, very much like the Wire.
When the Wire came out I was traumatized and
excited.
I was like, “I love this show, but I have
flashbacks.”
'Cause my neighborhood was just like the Wire,
you know, we had the drug dealing, the police
corruption, we had everything the Wire had,
right?
Except for universal critical acclaim, uh,
and the undying love of white people who saw
it.
Our neighborhood did not have that.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: But otherwise it was
very similar to the Wire.
So my mom help navigate me and my sister through
this environment and we had this very proud
moment at my college graduation from Harvard.
And she gave me this big hug and said, “We
did it!” and my sister is so proud of capturing
this moment, she’s like, “I’m the best
photographer ever.”
And so that’s kind of where I have come
from and it’s the foundation of what this
book is and kind of this conversation I wanna
start off with you guys here today.
So, let me talk about how the book was born,
first of all.
And there’s, there’s a lot of the personal
stuff in there.
But there’s also like a tech story too and
I think it’s pretty interesting to be talking
about that at Google.
The book was born on Twitter via a hash tag.
And essentially I was shopping for wine and
I didn’t know how to buy wine.
There’s all this history of wine flavors
and the air of frankincense or whatever, I
don’t know how to do all that stuff.
And I was also not interested in learning,
so, I just wanted a bottle of wine.
I went to the shop and I saw this brand of
wine called Negroamaro.
N-E-G-R, we’re gonna have to riot now aren’t
we?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: We’re just, this
is the black history month.
A black man can’t speak at Google without
some white guy talking loudly over top of
him.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: This is ridiculous.
I got 29 days man, c’mon.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Interrupt me in March
and I will not complain.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Anyway, I was talking
about my ignorant wine purchasing decisions.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So I saw this brand
of wine called Negroamaro, I was like, that
spoke to me, “Negro wine!
This is perfect.
That’s why I’m gonna buy it.”
So I posted to Twitter, and I was trying to
antagonize my friend, Elon James White who’s
a great comedian.
He does a web series called This Week in Blackness
and Blackin’ It Up.
And I said, “This weekend I picked my red
wine because it was called Negroamaro, that’s
how black I am.
Elon James, how black are you?”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I was just sort of
picking a fight playing a little joke back
and forth.
And then he responded, “I see the subtle
racial implication of Thunder Cat.
Panther was black, shirtless and Lionel’s
driver.
How black are you?”
And so we went back and forth, volleying and
hundreds of other people weighed in and threw
in their observations on how black are you.
Then the audience for this was a member of
the Harper Collins team, a woman named Debbie
Stier.
And she brought me in and we had a nice conversation
and said, “You should write a book.
Why don’t you write a book called how black
are you?”
And I was like, “Why don’t I not do that?”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: “That is a terrible
idea!”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Cause it was one thing
to have that conversation and that tension
and that battle between two people who know
each other, two people who are comedians and
we have assumed the best intentions.
I don’t wanna hit America with that.
I don’t trust America with that.
I just had visions of watermelons dancing
in my head.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: People are like, “How
black are you?
I drink grape soda all the time!”
And I’m like, ‘No, no, no.’
America’s not ready for how black are you
at the Wal Mart bookshelf, like we can’t
do that just yet.
We have some ways to go.
But they said, “What about how to be black?”
And I was like, “Yes!
That is ridiculous.
You can’t answer that, thus I want to try.”
And, uh, and be satirical about it, which
gives me some latitude and just have fun with
the impossible.
So the book was gonna be a series of “How
To” chapters.
The first one was “How to speak for all
black people” um, and “How to be the black
friend” “How to be the black employee.”
Which, clearly you guys might have an interest
in.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: “Tell us how to do
it!
Tell us how to do it!”
Its coming, its coming.
Just buy the book.
Uh, but, there was another part of, sort of
the product development of the book, that
I want to share what was not expected.
And I want to talk about the role that e-mail
played.
So I had this vision of, I’m gonna write
just a straight up satire set of chapters
on “How to.”
Separate from this, I operate an e-mail list.
I’ve been doing it for years.
I thought e-mail was dead.
I was like, “Ah, Facebook is here and Google
plus is here and Twitter is here.
Nobody reads e-mail anymore.”
But because we live in such a fast paced,
sort of, status update-isphere, I wanted to
have a deeper relationship with the people
who wanted a connection with me.
So the e-mail became a more of a behind the
scenes.
And rather than just promoting shows, and
doing a few one liner jokes, is that every
e-mail I send, I’m gonna have a true personal
story as a part of it.
So the same summer that I was doing the initial
rounds of writing this book, separate from
that I was sharing these personal stories
with my e-mail list.
And one story I shared, which really struck
a nerve, I told the story of my father’s
murder and what my memory of him was.
And I really only had six memories of this
dude.
He died when I was very young; he didn’t
live with us even for the time when he was
alive.
And I sent this out, I was on a bus, I was
on a Bolt bus to Boston, like a $15 bus, on
the Wi-Fi, banged this out in a couple hours,
sent it off.
And the flood of responses that came back
from my subscribers was overwhelming.
And one of those subscribers was my editor
at the time, Debbie Stier.
And she wrote, “This needs to go into the
book!”
And she’s like, “All these stories are
just too rich; you can’t not use them.
And I know it’s not part of the original
vision, but maybe we need to rethink what
this book should be.”
So she, “Just write those.
Don’t worry about the super hilarious stuff.
This is, and this was still funny.
Even the piece I wrote about my father’s
murder by gunshot was still darkly hilarious,
uh, if you’re open to that.
Which I was, I’ve been doing this for a
while.
So I reconceived of what the book should be
and then personal memoir actually became the
heart of it.
So let’s talk about what’s inside, between
these pages, between these bytes, in the electronic
version.
First off, it is my life.
It is the story of a young black dude who
has an eccentric black background, and not
just black background, obviously there’s
more to me then black.
But there is that story that people have heard
a lot of, that inner city, single mother,
gun violence and drugs thing.
That’s one.
There’s the Afrocentric rearing the fact
that I have a Nigerian name and I’m not
Nigerian.
[laughter] I remember I had a friend that
was Nigerian when I was growing up and I called
him on the phone, and his Nigerian father
answered and he’s like, “Hello?
Who’s calling?”
And I was like, “Oh, sir this is Baratunde.”
I might have been like 12 years old.
“Where did you get that name?”
Its like, how do you even answer that first
of all?
I got it, oh I don’t know, the secret stash
of names that are mine.
I got it from my parents.
And he’s like, “Well do you even know
what it means?”
And I was like, “Yeah.”
And this is why I was really proud, cause
I had this super Afrocentric mother.
She’s like, “You have to understand all
this stuff.”
And I was like, “Literally it means Grandfather
returns or father returns.
Or one that was chosen” And he’s like,
“No!
No. it means grandfather returns or one who
was chosen.”
It’s like, I just said that.
Just said, you know how adults can be with
respect to children, they can’t hear you.
Then he went on a rampage.
He was like, “This is the problem with you
African Americans.
You have no history.
No culture.
No roots.
You think you can wear a dashiki, steal an
African name and become African.
You cannot.”
I was like, “Dude, I just learned how to
add last week, like slow down.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Why are you hating
on me?
I’m a baby.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Pick a fight with someone
your own ignorance.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So the book has stories
like that.
It also has a lot of the “How to’s”
There’s how to, how to be the next black
president, one of my favorite chapters.
A lot of restrictions around president Obama,
especially his relationship to black America
and black people.
Certain issues he can’t talk about because
they think he’s gonna like, reinstitute
white slavery.
Yes, I said reinstitute.
We tried it once; it lasted for like a day.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And so there’s, you
know, some, some guidelines for the next black
president.
And also the theory being that the second
black president really is the first black
president, cause the next time around America’s
doing it super intentional, like we know what
we’re gonna get.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So number 2 is actually
number 1.
And then I, uh, so it created a panel.
And I didn’t wanna interview too many people.
So I picked seven folks, I call them the black
panel.
People who I thought were doing blackness
well.
And differently than what we commonly see.
And so here’s who’s on that panel.
There is three black women, starting with
Demali Ayo.
Demali is a performance artist and a writer.
She wrote a book called Obamastan: Land without
Racism.
I came across her in about 2003 when I was
just early in my own stand-up career and I
found this website called rentanegro dot com.
I was like, “What in the world is that?”
It was just hilarious, satirical product offering
where she’s like, “Look white people have
a lot of questions of their black friends.
We need to monetize this and set up some sort
of leasing system.”
So she had rentanegro dot com, she had prices.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: She had all this stuff.
She was inspired by this other dude, Keith
Obadike , who tried to auction off his blackness
on E-Bay.
And, uh, and sold it for not enough money.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So Demali, she’s
gotta be in the book, gotta be in the book.
It turns out that we went to the same high
school with the same friends.
I didn’t even know that until we started
talking.
Cheryl Contee, she is the co-founder with
me of Jack and Jill Politics.
Based in the Bay area, runs a social media
strategy firm.
Um, Jacquetta Szathmari, she was someone I
did not know at all.
A friend connected me to her.
A black woman who lives up in Riverside up
in the Bronx, Libertarian, and grew up in
the eastern shore of Maryland.
She was like my rural vector.
I was like, “Okay, let’s not keep it too
city focused.”
And she had a bunch of great stories to share.
And then I had three black men.
I had Kamau Bell who’s a Bay area comedian.
[Applause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah, can we clap for
them?
Kamau, he, uh, I like this dude.
I remembered hearing about him cause people
kept saying like, “I was like the Kamau
of the east.”
Or he was the Baratunde of the west.
Why can’t black dudes just be each other?
Like why do you have to?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: But um, he has a great
one man show called The W. Kamau Bell Curve,
which is a playoff of the Bell Curve book
by Charles Murray.
Who incidentally, Charles Murray has a new
book out about whiteness and I love that he
launched it during black history month.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Just couldn’t let
us have it, right?
Anyway, Kamau’s show, the subtitles is ending
racism in about an hour.
And he puts his money where his mouth is,
if you show up with a friend of a different
race, you get in for half price.
So that’s kind of nice.
That’s kind of nice.
Elon James White, who I mentioned earlier,
Brooklyn based comedian, This Week in Blackness
and Blacking it Up, web shows.
Derrick Ashong, who is a musician primarily,
but also a speaker and a TV host.
He has a band called Soulfege, he works for
Al Jazeera English.
And Derrick, for me, also represented a bit
of the diaspora because he was born in Ghana.
He was raised in all around the Middle East
in Qatar, Saudi Arabia.
And he spend his teen years and after in the
east coast, in the Philadelphia, New Jersey
area.
So he was kind of that global brother.
And then I had one white guy, uh, on the panel
because I didn’t want to get hit with charges
of reverse racism.
And I wanted a control group cause this is
a science project as well.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And so I picked the
whitest guy I could find, who’s Christian
Lander, who is the author of Stuff White People
Like.
And help create that amazing set.
And I really wanted the idea, like the idea
of a white comedian commenting on how to be
black was just too good to not try.
And he came through.
So what I wanna share now is, uh, some of
the questions that I asked these people.
I asked them, “When did you first realize
you were black?”
“How black are you?”
“Did you ever wish you weren’t black?”
“Can you swim?”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: A very important question.
“How’s that post-racial thing workin out
for you?” and, “What do you wish for the
future of black people and race in general
in America?”
So seven people, seven questions.
It’s a nice grid of 49 clips.
And then what I did was I video recorded them
and also use a zoom audio mic to get some
good audio.
So here is a sample of one of those clips.
[Pause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Oh, I should press
play.
This is a compilation around one of the answers.
[Music plays]
>> Female #1: So, I came home and I remember
I couldn’t really move past the entrance
of the house.
And I need to talk about the fact that this
little girl said that I was black when I,
in fact, found myself to be beige.
[Music plays]
>> Male #1: I was playing doctor with a bunch
of kids and, uh, when this one girl, it was
her turn to kiss me and she didn’t.
And she sort of ran away laughing, the kids
ran away laughing.
And the thing I realized at that point is
that I was black and they were all white because
this was a small private school in Boston.
And that was the first time I remember feeling
like black was somehow separate from the norm,
you know.
I think I knew I was black before then because,
as I say in my show, my mom would not have
not let me know that I was black.
[Laughs]
>> Male #1: There would have been no way that
she would have let that information slip.
“It’s cold outside take a jacket and you’re
black”.
[Laughter]
[Music plays]
>> Male #2: I was born in Africa, so everybody’s
black.
[Laughter]
>> Male #2: So, we don’t really think about
it like that.
I mean here it’s like “Is he black?
Is he white?”
In Africa, like, you don’t ask.
The assumption is that you’re black.
Therefore, what becomes more important is
other things.
What your name is, where you come from, what
language do you speak, what’s your culture,
what’s your tribe etcetera.
So I knew I was black.
When I was eight, I moved to the Middle East.
I think the Middle East is the first time
I discovered I was black.
Because people would come up to you and they’d
be like,
[Inaudible]
>> Male #3: And what does that translate to?
>> Male #2: That means this little black guy.
[Laughter]
[Music plays]
Male #4: I grew up in East Chinatown in Toronto.
So it was made very clear that I was gweilo
from a very early--
Male #3: Gweilo?
Meaning?
Male #4: White ghost.
So I know every derogatory term for a white
person in Chinese.
[Music plays]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So that’s some of,
you know what people have to say in the book.
In the enhanced version, we have a lot of
those clips built in.
And in the audio version, instead of me reading
their words, you actually hear them saying
what they say and you can hear the backgrounds
of the neighborhoods they live in and I really
wanted it to be an audio experience.
I did the reading myself, uh, as well because
black people can read now, it’s pretty awesome.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Uh, so I wanna talk
about that process.
You know, give a little behind the scenes
of the writing process.
And this is the sort of, uh, the route that
I came up with.
I tried to write this book in summer of 2010,
I sort of missed my target.
I told you about the reengineering around
memoir, so summer 2011 was it.
I had a drop dead deadline, July 15th.
And those last four weeks, this was all I
did.
I woke up, I ate, I wrote, I biked into work,
I took a break, I wrote, I took another break,
I wrote, I biked home and kind of wash, rinse,
repeat.
I also wanted to play with the community of
people who knew this book was coming.
Folks who were interested in what I had to
do.
So I was trying to use the web in some interesting
ways.
When I did the interviews I would check in
on four square and use the hash tag how to
be black.
I was sharing snippets of what I wrote on
Facebook and on my Google plus page.
And so this was a chapter I wrote about what
It means, “How to be the black employee.”
And folks were just really, you know, we had
a lot of good feedback, uh, on that early
moment.
Even as I was writing I was like, “Okay,
is this gonna write my sort of how to be black
beta project?”
I also got some amazing feedback and I wanna
share just a few slices of what people had
to say as they looked over my virtual shoulder.
Some woman said, “This book is clearly not
written for black folks.
It’s too wordy and there’s no pictures.”
That was one of my Facebook fans that wrote
that.
So I wrote her back and saying, “Can someone
please translate this for me?
I can’t understand it without pictures.”
Uh, so that was pretty interesting.
Someone else wrote, “This book is solely
based on ignorance.
Martin Luther King, Junior would be ashamed
if he read this.
Good job with settin us back fifty years,
dick.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: There’s a lot to
unpack from that.
First of all, he has a direct channel with
the ghost of Martin Luther King, which I think
is amazing that we haven’t heard from this
dude before.
I also like that he called me a dick, that’s
really nice.
That’s really nice.
But mostly I like how he spelled “solely.”
S-O-U-L-Y, which is kinda black.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And I was like, “Maybe
I should listen to this dude.
Maybe I’m, maybe the public knows more than
me about this.”
I got an e-mail from a friend of mine during
this process.
His name is Anand Giridharadas, he’s a New
York Times columnist, written a book called
India Calling.
He’s become a very good friend.
And he said, “I have an amazing idea for
you as a publicity stunt, create a public
writing viewing for your final day of writing
the book.”
He’s in this screen sharing service called
Join dot Me.
You can share your screen with the world.
And so I did that.
I actually, when he wrote, I wrote him back
immediately, a really long e-mail explaining
why this is a terrible idea and no author
should ever do this.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: But as I wrote those
words I convinced myself otherwise and decided
to give it a shot.
And so I called it My Live Writing Exercise.
And I was remembering a friend of mine who
does the live painting, Marc Scheff, and he
allows you to see him actually paint, digitally,
using a Wacom Tablet.
And, uh, I’ve seen stuff like that with
construction.
But never with words, I hadn’t seen someone
do that before.
So, when people came, this is the screen that
they would see.
It had a little billboard explaining what
was going on.
You were watching @Baratunde write How to
Be Black keep the hash tag going.
Please don’t like, I’m not gonna be chatting
with you.
People were trying to take control of my machine.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Because you’re gonna
have that happen.
And like, “I wanna help you!”
I’m like, “No!
No!
This is still me writing.
You get to watch.
Right?
You get to watch.”
So they started chatting with each other as
I generally, uh, ignored them.
I did take one major tip from this audience.
I had this chapter called Going Back to Africa,
which is about my first trip to Senegal when
I was in high school.
And someone said, “You should call it Going
Black to Africa” And I was like, “Obviously,
I should.”
And so I did.
And I don’t know who that was, it was like
chatuser0056, but uh, they get a little credit
for making the book even blacker.
Uh, so this is what people had to say as they
were in the chat room.
“This is really what the internet is all
about, gives me a connection with the author.”
“How self-obsessed does one have to be to
set something like this up?”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: The answer is very.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Uh, I have a lot of
self-love.
“Update them to theme and I’ll leave you
alone.”
A lot of people were obsessed with typos during
live writing.
I’m like, “I will go back and fix those.”
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: We have editors and
copy editors, like, please don’t get caught
up on it.
But a lot of people have a little OCD about
the spelling.
“I’ve watched cartoonists before, but
this is very different.”
“Just the little I’ve read here makes
me want to buy this book.”
Yes!
Good.
I should follow up and make sure they did
it and they weren’t just lying.
“I have an urge to tweet about this.”
Good.
“It’s interesting to see his writing flow.”
“I’m surprised to see Baratunde use semi-colons.”
Which again I’m like, “Why?
Is it cause I’m black?
Like, I don’t understand.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Like, “Is that, am
I not supposed to use semi-colons?
Or is it something that I project into the
world?”
We just know from my writing and my tweets
and my stand up, this dude doesn’t use semi-colons.
What is he up to?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Somebody else is writing
this book.
Somebody in Norway was watching which I love
because that is a super white nation.
And so I’m like, “He is gonna get a little
direct access to blackness.”
This is my favorite comment by far though.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: “My girlfriend is
Chinese and I’m half Jamaican, half regular
black.”
So let’s just pause on “regular black.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Cause you got Black
Zero, Diet Black.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Black macchiato.
Like, I just want regular black.
“I think our kids might end up Dominican
or something.”
Which is cool cause when you look at the projections
of, you know, demographics and inter marrying,
like, everyone will kind of look Dominican.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Puerto Rican, light
skin Indian.
You know, it’s pretty, we’re all gonna.
How to be Brown is really what I should have
written.
That’s what I’m saying.
It’s a plan for the future.
Future proof my book.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Uh, and so then, finally
I wanna talk about kind of taking the spirit
of all that, the life this is wrapped around,
the way it was written in a semi open fashion.
I wanted the marketing to be a bit different,
the extra from might typically be done.
So Harper and I developed a really good partnership.
They got a lot of great media, uh, for me
and with me.
I was able to do Terry Gross, Fresh Air, which
is just like, she’s my hero.
She’s this big by the way.
I almost destroyed her by just sitting on
her.
Terry Gross is the tiniest person.
So I would almost have to apologize to the
world.
But the first thing we do, well behind the
scenes, is set up a virtual street team.
And I had taken some cues from Seth Godin
around this and wanted to tweak it for our
own campaign.
So we recruited people, we got over 100 people
folks to sign up to help spread the message
of the book in their own way.
So they got the book early.
I wanted them to blog about it, and they were
not all black.
This was an international crew, men and women,
um, Asian and Latin American, all kinds of
folks able to find a connection with some
of these stories.
Cause the story, black is sort of the variable,
how to be is sort of the heart of the story.
I contacted everybody I knew.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: This is Ms. Cleo for
those who don’t know.
And I’m just like dialing for dollars is
very much a political campaign metaphor for
this whole thing.
And I’m still reaching out one by one.
I talked to an author, I talked to Gary Vaynerchuk,
and I’m like, “What’s the one thing
you think I should do?”
He said, “Well did I ask you to buy my book?”
I was like, “Nope.”
And he’s like, “That was a miss.”
He’s like,” You have all these followers
who are actually friends.
I didn’t hit you up personally.
The one thing you could do that would be most
effective in getting your book out there is
to talk to people one on one.
Just do it.
Do the hard work.”
And show the shoe leather We got a little
crazy.
I have a, I’m working with someone.
I hired an assistant to help me through this
whole process.
His title is campaign manager, again sticking
with the theme.
He’s white so his nickname is “white shadow.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And he, we were talking
on Skype, I was traveling overseas and I’m
like, “Why don’t we create a black card?
Like, wouldn’t it be crazy if we created
a black card?”
He’s like, “Yes, that would be crazy.”
And, uh, but we did it.
We actually did it.
So if you go to gotblackness dot com.
It’s a pl--; we printed up a bunch of these.
It’s a plastic card with a magnetic strip.
On it there’s a RFid, or I forget, a QR
code.
There’s a concierge line to call with all
your racial questions.
And here’s what the card does, it’s sort
of, One, it gets you 24 seven to the white
house, so long as there’s a black president.
So there’s an incentive to re-elect Obama.
Two, you can have police custody for any racially
motivated, uh, holding.
Stop and frisk and stuff like that.
I know you guys have issues in the Bay area
with that just flash your black card.
You can win any racial argument if you violently
slam the card down on the table.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And you are declared
an official friend to black people.
So it’s a really cool flexible model.
You got to activated it through text messaging.
We use things like if this, then that to help
us with is.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: It’s insane.
Uh, actually, in fact, you know what, let
me just show you.
I’m gonna go over to the live thing.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Alright so here’s,
uh, let me just show you some of our members.
So Ron Williams, Ron J. Williams CEO of Knodes
start up out of Brooklyn.
He says, “I could never get a cab to take
me to Brooklyn due to the color of my skin.
Now that I have the black card, and a phalanx
of lawyers trained by the ghost of Johnny
Cochran, I get justice.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Newt Gingrich, temporarily
US popular politician, “I make outlandish
comments about black people with almost no
consequences.
It’s because I’m a proud holder of the
black card.
I never leave home without it.
Now get off those food stamps, Negroes.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Then this one, this
is really adorable.
This is a young member.
There’s no age restriction, no ageism in
the black card.
This is Cormack, who is a white child, “I’m
3 years old.
Thanks to the black card, I will never know
a life filled with white guilt.
Doesn’t your child deserve the same opportunity
I get?”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So, you know, people
can apply for membership with this card.
It’s a very exclusive program.
But, I’m very proud of what we’ve been
able to do there to kind of spread blackness.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And we’re doing a
lot of live events.
Talks like this, throwing launch parties and
trying to keep the theme very black in the
party.
So, in D.C.
I’m doing an after party at a bar called
Blackbird.
We got Black Grouse Whiskey co- sponsoring,
Brooklyn Beer, Black Chocolate Stout, so just
all black everything, uh, is the theme of
that.
And we have, actually this is very important,
there are two versions of the book.
There is a black cover with white text and
a white cover with black text.
If you order online you don’t know which
one you’re gonna get, you can’t request
a specific one.
We’ve actually developed; I think you guys
at Google would be very proud of this, a racial
profiling algorithm that determines which
book you need most and delivers that one to
you.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So for folks who insist,
like “I really want a white version, or
I really want a black version.”
Just keep ordering the books until you get
the one you want.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: People of mixed race
or other race, are like, “Which one am I
supposed to get?”
“You’re supposed to buy both.”
{Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So, it’s a very,
uh, pro-growth program around this book.
And we set up this website, howtobeblack dot
me, where every day in February, and probably
beyond, we’re asking the same questions
that are shared in those chapters to the public.
“When did you first realize you were black?”
“How black are you?” and the stuff people
are saying, again, is pretty amazing.
Here’s a few I queued up, “I’m a graduating
senior, black female, mechanical engineering
major from Georgia Tech and I cannot swim.”
Uh, this is another story that someone shared,
“I realized I was black when they asked
me to Crip walk.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Alright.
“I literally scared the heck out of folks
who had never a black brother that far out
in the ocean.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Sort of like black
spotting, I guess.
I don’t know what that is.
“You from Brooklyn and you don’t like
rap?
You ain't black!”
So people share all these stories and, uh,
we wanna kind of keep that going well beyond
the book.
The book’s not supposed to be some final
chapter, so there’s a party that we wanna
invite everyone to.
This photo, by the way, was shot by Neal Brennan.
He co-created the Chappelle’s Show.
He’s a stand-up comic.
I gave him the book, he rid down a New York
subway, he was like mobbed by these four black
dudes like, “What are you holding?
What is that?”
And so there inspecting.
And I like the dude in the back far right,
who clearly already knows how to be black
and is not interested at all.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So that is my formal
presentation.
I’d love to take your questions and we can
all get a little blacker.
I’m Baratunde and thank you.
[Applause]
>>Male #4: I was talking to Joe, and then
he’s like, “I think we got it working.”
>>Male #5: Yeah, it started working as soon
as you walked out.
>>Male #4: Oh.
[Laughter]
>>Male #5: They didn’t want you to be black,
that’s why it stopped.
[Laughter]
>>Male #4: Stopped it.
>> Baratunde Thurston: What is going on here?
Hi Mike!
Oh, please say something racist.
Please!
Somebody’s gonna lose their job today.
Oh!
[Laughter]
[Inaudible]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah, there’s a,
for those in the room, mic right there.
Please use that to ask all your blackness
questions.
>> Female #2: I apologize for my ignorance;
I don’t get the swimming joke.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: You know what, that’s
a good, that’s a good point.
She said, “I don’t get the swimming joke.”
I have an answer but does any black person
here wanna address that.
Cause we can go peer to peer on this.
Please, go over to the mic.
[Laughter]
[Inaudible]
>> Baratunde Thurston: We want, please, use
the, he’ll hand you a mic.
Don’t talk yet.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Don’t talk yet.
And when you answer say your name if you’re
comfortable, if you’re not you can hide
behind your blackness.
[Laughter]
>> Female #3: it’s okay, don’t be ashamed.
Um, my name’s Elica and I work in Android
for the Google music store.
So one of the things, I think one of the main
things that keep black people from swimming
so much, so most black people, I think, grow
up not learning how to swim.
I think one of the main things that keeps
us from learning is our hair.
[Laughter]
>> Female #3: That was, that was a big, big
impediment for me.
Um, but, unfortunately, I mean, fortunately,
for me my mom put braids in my hair and she
put me in the pool and made me get swim lessons.
But I had girlfriends later I would try to
get to go to the pool they were like, “Uh-uh,
my mom just pressed my hair.”
Or “I did this, you know, I got a jerry
curl.”
You know, so all kind of things with hair
that, you know, really keep a lot of black
people from learning.
And, I guess also just fear of sharks, maybe.
[Laughter]
>> Female #3: I don’t know, but I kind of
break some of those barriers but, you know,
some people still are.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Thank you.
Do you have an addendum to this?
Yeah?
>> Female #4: My name is Judith Williams;
I work on the diversity team here at Google.
And I’m probably a little bit older than
most of you here so you might not remember,
but Howard Cosell, who was a sports journalist.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>>Female #4: He made this famous comment about
how black people can’t swim because we sink.
And that caused a huge uproar.
So for me that’s one of the reasons why
it’s funny.
>> Baratunde Thurston: There is a, thank you
very much.
Thank you both.
I like that we crowd sourced that a little
bit.
There’s also, in terms of the economics
of it, you know there’s been a historical
lack of access to pools or segregation around
pools that kind of seeped into the community
over time.
I ask this question to people, we have the
video on the site, but Jacquetta was a, she
grew up on the eastern shore and she’s like,
“You can’t not swim, you live right next
to the ocean.
If something could happen, I wanna know how
to do it.”
She was outlandish in that way.
Kamau probably knew how to swim but he said,
“I can’t float very well cause I’m six
foot two, 250 pounds build for slavery and
the revolution.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So that’s very important
to keep in mind as well, if you’re built
for the revolution, you may be slower in the
water.
Any other questions or comments?
Yeah?
>> Female #5: Okay.
I’m here again.
So I know that you’re alum of my alma mater.
And.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Which one are we talking?
>> Female #5: Harvard.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Harvard, cool.
>> Female #3: And one of the things that I
found was, when I was at Harvard, there was
a lot of pulling the black card, shall we
say, or challenges.
And I’m wondering how your experiences at
a black student Harvard might have informed
some of your later stand-up and your book
and some of the things you talk about.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yes, so I have, I have
a chapter in the book called Black, “Being
Black at Harvard.”
I had good preparation for the Harvard environment.
I went to boot camp, also known as private
white high school.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And, I went to Sidwell
Friend School, where the Obama daughters go,
where Chelsea Clinton was two years behind
me.
And that was my big cultural adjustment.
I’d been in D.C. public schools before then
and my neighborhood was all black and Latino.
There were two white kids in my class in grade
school.
One was William, one was Willamina.
So as far as I knew all white people had the
same name.
So Sidwell was culture shock.
I had Ebonics when I showed up.
I axed people questions.
It’s a very long road.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I’ve gotten through
it now, I’ve gotten through it.
I got treatment.
And, so Harvard for me was very liberating
because I’d gone through the whole process
of being the minority in the educational institution.
Harvard certainly keeps changing in the types
of black people that go there, too.
At the time that I was there, I think half
or to just slightly majority were not American
native black, but were immigrants from some
other place, from the Caribbean from across
the Diaspora.
That changes things, that changes thing culturally.
We also have people who much, many more people
over the history of Harvard who’ve had a
private school background, mixing with those
who have public school background, mixing
with those from the Diasporic background.
So I did not, I was one of those dudes that
like hung out with the blackity black crowd
and like sat at the black table.
But also I, like, I talked to white people
because they were there and had knowledge
in their brains that I wanted, and friendship
in their hearts.
So I think I had a pretty idealized experience
because I was so very prepared.
I don’t know that everyone had that experience.
You know everyone’s got their own college
experience, too.
I would like to think that the mix of the
type of black people in each Harvard class
over time contributes to a little bit less
of the black card pulling.
Except for mine, which I hope to monetize
and get all those people to invest using the
black card.
Thank you.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Anybody else?
Step right up.
>> Male #6: Alright.
My name is Biola.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Biola, hello.
>> Male #6: So, um, I understand you have
an Arabic name, and a British name as well.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah, yeah.
My middle name
>> Male #6: Do you ever…?
>> Baratunde Thurston: What’s up?
Go ahead.
>> Male #6: Yeah, do you ever have to pull
out the black card to validate your blackness?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I don’t have to pull
out the black card yet, I think people can
just sense that I have it in my wallet.
Um, my middle name is Rafiq, R-A-F-I-Q, which
means friend or companion.
And my last name is Thurston which means that
was the guy that owned my people.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Um, so my name in comb--.
Baratunde Rafiq in combination is supposed
to mean kingly companion.
That was what my mother was going for.
Yeah, and I don’t, I don’t really have
patience for the black card being pulled thing.
And, uh, I know I’m black.
[Laughs]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And I think the self-knowledge
and the confidence to not be buffeted by the
external pressures from all kinds of people.
You know, there's this weird identity matrix,
right?
Where there’s like who you are and who the
world expects you to be, whether you’re
a woman, whether you’re black, whether you’re
gay, whether you’re white dude, whatever.
There’s always a gap in those things.
And within the black matrix, there’s inside
the black community, “You’re not black
enough because you’re not thug or hood or
whatever.”
Or, “You’re not black enough cause you
don’t hate white people enough.
“
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Or “Cause you’re
radically political enough.”
Derrick had a great story about some folks
at a new Black Panther party in Boston saying
he’s not black enough and he’s like, “I’m
from Africa.
You cannot out black me, I win.
I always win.”
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: It’s just like.
So, and then, from the externally, you know
non blacks and black, those same switches
exist.
There’s like a mux right here with all these
different channels of blackness.
And I think, what I hope will happen and what
I sort of see happening, though I’m in a
little bit of a bubble myself, is that in
part because of tech and part because we can
put out new images of what black is.
We’re gonna have to just rely on the main
stream MTV commercialized vision of the archaized,
sassy black woman.
Like, you can be more than that.
You know what I’m saying?
Thugged out, I’m wearing a hoodie but I’m
clearly not very thug.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So, cause I would never,
a thug would never say, “I’m clearly not
very thug.”
With that inflection.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So as we are able to
project more of our full selves out into the
world instead of compete with those images.
And demonstrate that there’s a market for
you.
You have Awkward Black Girl, Black Nerd Comedy,
This Week in Blackness, as examples.
We can close that gap a little bit more and
have our black cards called a lot less.
Yeah?
>> Female #6: Hello, thank you.
My name is Chastity.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Hello Chastity.
>> Female #6: Um, and I onboard all of our
new employees here at Google.
And your visit couldn’t be more timely because
I’m in an argument with my boyfriend.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
>> Female #6: Over something like.
[Laughter]
>> Female#6: Wait, wait!
Let me explain.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Please explain.
>> Female #6: To give you background, I’m
from Portland Oregon.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Okay.
>> Female #6: He’s from Philadelphia Pennsylvania.
>>Baratunde Thurston: Hold on, we got a little
racism happening right now.
Just a little bit.
>> Female #6: Okay.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: Just a smidgen.
>> Baratunde Thurston: I’m just--
>> Female #6: So I’m from Portland, he’s
from Philly; we have two completely different
backgrounds.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: But, last night, we were watching
an episode of the Chappelle’s Show, there
was a segment where he brings people out and
he asked them questions.
I think its like, “How well do you know
black people?”
It was something like that.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: So he would ask someone, “What’s
a Lucy?” and, so, my boyfriend would turn
to me and say.
“Babe, what’s a Lucy” And I’m like,
“I don’t know.”
And so the next question was like a character
on Good Times that I didn’t know.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: But, “Who is that?” and
I’m like, “I don’t know.”
So then he asked me one more question
>>Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: And I yelled at him, I was like,
“I Don’t Know!”
[Laughter]
>> Female #6: And so we got into this argument,
and he says that it’s not his fault that
I’m insecure about my blackness.
Or lack thereof.
[Laughter]
>> Female #6: So, what I need from you, this
isn’t a question it’s more of a request.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: I need something that I can
say to counter him when I see him today.
[Laughter]
>> Female #6: I need your help.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #6: It’d be better if you could
just tweet him and play him in front of all
of the world, but if not.
>> Baratunde Thurston: What?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Wow!
You are really, you are asking me, first of
all, I think this is a fascinating moment.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: And I kinda gotta respect
your gusto and your boldness because I don’t
know your boyfriend and I don’t know his
side of your story.
[Laughter]
>> Female #6: Oh!
>> Baratunde Thurston: And you’re asking
me to violate potential bro code here.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Which I just, like,
he’s from Philly.
Like, I have mad love for Philly.
I’m from the east coast so I’m not tryin
to do all that.
Without.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: But I will share though,
there is, you’ve reminded me of a funny
story from the book.
From Jacquetta, again she’s the eastern
shore Maryland native, and she’s like, “I
don’t understand black folks from Chicago
and LA, like I don’t know what they’re
saying when they talk.”
Because it’s just a different language,
it’s a different community.
She’s like, “We need some kind of translation,
some kind of app, to help one type of black
person talk to another type.”
So if the book does well enough, I’ll be
proud to announce the Negretta Stone App.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Which would allow,
like, inter black communication.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And maybe you and your
boyfriend can,
>> Female #6: Yeah, I think that’s what
I need.
>> Baratunde Thurston: like Beta test it.
>> Female #6: So just let me know, when it
comes out.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah, Cause I just,
I hope your relationship can withstand this.
>> Female #6: We’ll see.
I don’t know.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Wow, I mean there are
other, there are good things in this relationship,
too, or is this the only thing you do?
>> Female #6: Good things.
There are good things.
>> Baratunde Thurston: You actually like him?
Like he smells good?
Like all this kind of stuff?
>> Female #6: Thank you.
[Laughter]
>>Female #6: Yes.
>> Baratunde Thurston: My goodness Chastity.
>> Female #6: Thank you.
Just pokin a little fun.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Thank you.
Tell him to take it easy on you, though.
Tell him to take it easy.
Best as I can see, you’re black.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And I’m kind of an
authority cause I’ve been black for over
30 years.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: How we doin?
Anybody else?
Going once.
Any remo- are the remote people allowed to
talk?
>> Audience member: Yes.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Anybody on the Google
hangout?
[Pause]
>> Baratunde Thurston: If you’re talking
we cannot hear you, just so you know.
>> Audience Member: Ping Camille.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Ping Camille.
What did I, no what does that mean?
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I just yelled out words.
>> Baratunde Thurston: I could have launched
something.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: What did you do?
>> Baratunde Thurston: It’s like Ender’s
Game or something up in here.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I just wiped out a
race.
Or some secret Google hack.
[Laughter]
>>Audience Member: Austin has a question.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Okay, you can relay
them.
Go ahead.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: I’m Sorry.
[Pause]
>> Male #7: Can you hear us now?
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yes!
>> Male #7: Oh hooray!
One question, it’s a little off topic but
I saw that you were an editor for The Onion
and I just wanted to get your experience what
that was like working with that group.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yes, I am at The Onion,
I still am at The Onion.
Thanks for firing me with your use of tense.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: What was it like to
have that job that you used to have?
That you don’t know that you don’t have
anymore?
By the way, I have your job.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: No, I’ve been with
The Onion since, we can maybe move him VC
people, he’s like coughing or dying or something.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: And I just need him
to die quietly so I can answer his question.
Maybe his kids can hear it.
I’ve been with The Onion since the fall
of 2007.
I was hired on as Politics editor initially
to help plot and plan and coordinate our election
coverage.
Also as web editor to help bring us into the
future digitally even more than we already
were.
My title now is Director of Digital.
I made up that title because it sounded better.
And it has D-O-D, which sounds pretty bad
ass and I like bad ass job titles.
So it’s been amazing.
I mean, I do love working there.
I’ve been into comedy for a very long time.
I’ve been doing stand-up for over a decade.
Being at one of the premier comedy institutions
the world has to offer has been great.
And to be able to kind of play on this line
between journalism and comedy and satire and
all, it’s just very fun.
We’re sort of in this enthrones of digital
essence and like, “What does it mean to
be a content company in the inter webs?”
And are able to kind of mock that, but also
participate in it in really fun ways.
And they provide healthcare, which is amazing.
So yeah, the healthcare isn’t amazing, it’s
okay, but the fact that I have it, is awesome
in America.
>> Female #7: We have a question from Tenecia,
>>Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>>Female #7: who is pinging from some place
here in,
>> Baratunde Thurston: Somewhere black I’m
guessing.
>> Female #7: Can you, I’m asking you if,
uh, you’ve ever considered appearing on
an episode of Awkward Black Girl or helping
them write material for the website.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: That’s funny.
It reminds me of a question.
I probably will answer that, but I wanna tell
this story instead.
When I was doing my stand-up thing people
were like, “Yo, have you ever considered
being on the Tonight Show with Jay Leno?
Or maybe you should do SNL or something.”
I was like, “Maybe I should have dreams
and pursue them, thank you.”
So I have not, it would never occur to me
to, like, presume upon her show, Issa Rae.
But I do, I’m a big fan of the show.
And I’d be happy to make an appearance,
Issa.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: So if you want me on
your show, no pressure, but everybody on the
internet would watch it.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I don’t know.
You should watch the show.
It’s kind of, I think it’s kind of a weird
question but I, I, I chose to answer it the
way that I did and now it’s part of the
permanent record.
Good.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Who else?
Anyone else?
Yes?
>>Female #8: I have a question.
Good afternoon, my name is Charlay.
First of all, thank you for coming.
I think you’re hilarious.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Thank you.
>> Female #8: I was a little bit weary when
I saw the counter invite.
I was like, “OK, this guy is gonna tell
me how to be black, I think I already know
how to do that.”
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: I don’t need nobody
tellin me how to be black!
>> Female #8: It’s been really great so
thank you.
My question is, since you are apparently a
foremost expert on blackness.
[Laughter]
>> Female #8: I wanted to know, I wanted to
know, in your opinion, what is it that makes
someone black, because like Chastity was mentioning
culture varies depending on where you live.
Like, if you don’t speak a certain way,
people might feel like you’re black enough.
And really it’s not even skin tone anymore
because my cousin, you know, looks like a
white girl.
So I just wanted to know, is there one thing
that makes somebody black, or is it hard to
define?
>>Baratunde Thurston: Oh, what makes someone
black?
Black parents help, at least one.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: I would never say that
it’s some checklist of cultural markers
and knowledge cause that’s, that’s a falsely
limiting thing.
But I also, we also know that scientifically
speaking, there’s no such thing as race,
if you wanna go to the genetic thing and try
to define it that way.
It’s in between those two falsehoods.
There’s a truth of blackness which is some
history, which is some phenotypical set of
things, some, but not exclusively.
You have very white looking black people.
You have very black looking white peo- no.
You don’t have any black looking white people.
But, um, yeah the idea, I also would be very
careful of this idea that anyone can just
declare themselves to be black.
I remember there was a rap group, maybe in
the early 90s, Young Black Teenagers.
And they’re like, “Blackness isn’t a
race, it’s a state of mind, man.”
It’s like, no, it’s not.
You can’t just write yourself in as a candidate
for blackness.
And that’s a little, that level of flexibility
is a little dangerous.
But we’re in some magical times where those
cultural markers are open to so many people.
When you put the popularity of entertainment
especially Hip Hop.
Hip Hop’s such a global culture started
very black but has grown far beyond that.
Being in rap doesn’t make you black.
It makes you really into Hip Hop.
But it doesn’t change your race.
This book doesn’t make anyone black.
It can make you look blacker, I think, by
sharing some of a black experience that you
may not have heard about and having some fun
with it.
So I’m gonna ramble through that answer
and say there’s no, there’s no measure
of black to be in and out.
You kinda know it, if you are.
And if you’re not, then that’s cool too.
[Pause]
>>Baratunde Thurston: You might be the last
one.
Yeah, you are the last one.
Congrats.
>> Female #9: I am the last one?
>> Baratunde Thurston: Make it amazing.
>>Female #9: Oh, gosh the pressure.
I don’t know if it is but I’ll see.
I’m Mary and, um, I was raised, I grew up
in a predominately white area.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>>Female #9: There was about five black families.
>>Baratunde Thurston: Out of how many?
>>Female #9: Oh, I don’t know, like 30,000.
You know, central coast.
San Luis Obispo County, I don’t know if
you guys know where that is.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Okay.
>> Female #9: I grew up in a beach town and
I don’t know where to swim.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Just a moment of silence.
>> Female #9: I try, I try, I try.
But anyway, my parents always taught me to
speak to other black people.
So if I see other black people, maybe it’s
because it was predominately white.
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah.
>> Female #9: You speak to each other.
They say “Hi.”
And my white friends always find it funny
because they don’t walk around saying hi
to each other.
[Laughter]
>>Female #9: And I think the younger generation,
cause I’m older, so who said they were the
oldest in the room?
I bet I’m older.
But anyway.
>> Baratunde Thurston: She left, I think.
It was nap time.
I'm kidding.
>> Female #9: She was too old.
[Laughter]
>> Female #9: So the younger people don’t
do it.
So sometimes I’ll say hi and there like
well ya know?
I was just wondering did you grow up doing
that, or were you raised to do that?
>> Baratunde Thurston: Yeah, that’s.
Great question, great closing question.
I did grow up acknowledging other black people,
I still acknowledge other black people.
I think the folks who don’t do that, I think
it’s very regional, in my experience.
When I moved from D.C. to Boston I encountered
a level of coldness in the city that I’ve
never experienced.
I was always told that New York was a very
rough and cold town and Boston is much more
distant, you know, much more insider or outsider.
And not just among black people, with all
people.
People don’t say hi on the street in Boston.
Like, “What do you, what do you want?
“ Like, “Just a human connection.”
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: “You came to the wrong
city!
Get out!
Go back south!”
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: So I, I actually write
about this in “How to Be a Black Friend.”
I say one of the keys on the premise of this
being, you’re a black person, who is friends,
one of, if not only minority in the group
of non-black people especially white people,
you have an obligation to acknowledge other
black people.
Because you’re on a mission, you’re basically
an undercover agent.
And you’re delivering messages, and communication,
you’re learning, you’re preventing a race
war by telling your white friends not to touch
your hair or use the “N” word.
But if you don’t acknowledge other black
people it raises suspicions about your commitment
to the cause.
So I was always to, like, at least a head
nod, just a little something.
Maybe, maybe one of these, you know if you’re
really.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: If it’s the day, like,
if you’ve reached the moment when it’s
like it’s on, you got the memo.
It's like, “Let’s do it!”
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: Or maybe just a smile.
I just needed the subtle eye contact.
So I have not experienced much of, black people
were comfortable being black people but not
acknowledging other black people.
I think I have seen that among some that are
like, “I’m kind of undercover here.
I don’t want people to know that I know
that I’m black.”
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: So keep doing it.
We’ll try to train the younger generation
to stay on message and on mission.
[Laughter]
>>Baratunde Thurston: I am gonna end my talk
on this.
[Laughter]
>> Baratunde Thurston: Thank you Google, thank
you black people, thank you all people.
I’m Baratunde.